*bruitage*
Oh là, il n’est pas passé loin celui-ci.
Enfin bon, tout est relatif !
L’astéroïde 1998 OR2, c’est son nom,
est passé à 6,3 millions de km de la Terre.
Autrement dit 16 fois la distance Terre-Lune.
Pour vous donner une petite idée,
au mois de juillet 2019,
un autre astéroïde s’est approché de la Terre
à seulement 70 000 km.
Il mesurait une centaine de mètres.
Celui qui vient de s’approcher est plus volumineux.
Il mesure environ 2 km de diamètre.
Il est évident que si un caillou comme celui-ci
venait à percuter la Terre, on le sentirait passer.
Pour mémoire, l’astéroïde qui s’est abattu
sur notre planète il y a 66 millions d’années
et qui à provoquer la disparition des dinosaures, mesurait une dizaine de kilomètres.
Avec 1998 OR2,
nous n’avons absolument rien à craindre.
C’est un sujet parfait pour une « capsule de déconfiné ».
Il appartient à un groupe d’astéroïdes baptisé Amor
amour en espagnol,
dont on connaît parfaitement la trajectoire.
Elle frôle l’orbite de la Terre, sans jamais y pénétrer.
Franchement, il y a des trucs beaucoup plus petits
dont il faut davantage se méfier et se tenir à l’écart.
Si vous avez aimé cette « capsule de déconfiné » n’hésitez pas à laisser un pouce bleu.
Vous pouvez également voir et revoir celles des jours précédents en cliquant sur le côté gauche.
Pendant le confinement,
j’en réalise une nouvelle chaque jour.
Alors le mieux, pour ne pas en louper,
c’est de vous abonner et d’activer la petite cloche.
Allez à demain et n’oubliez pas,
nous sommes toujours confinés mais on reste en lien.